hello guys I am Ryan the right and I am
Brianna white so Brianna white I are
gonna check out chick check out check
out the official final trailer for
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice and I
like doing this with people who actually
haven't seen the prior installment
Briana hasn't seen Man of Steel and I
like doing that because I like seeing
like what if this trailer is so good
that it causes Briana to go I got to
watch this movie so I'm going to go back
and watch Man of Steel because in a lot
of ways trailers are a work of art you
know have to be they are they're so
taken for granted the only time we
really hear about a trailer the
criticism of a way of shows put together
is when it reveals too much yes you know
like you'll hear a great trailer but you
won't hear someone go the people that
design this trailer did a great job you
know know a good trailer is supposed to
make you think I have to see that movie
exactly not pointing to why laughs way
well Imaging is showing me two dozen
hostiles on the third floor why don't I
drop you off on the second there you go
baddie
nice oh yeah oh [ __ ] he's really
fighting I'm getting slow in my old age
shoppers even you got too old to die
young neck for lack of trying
okay now mom word has the power to wipe
out the entire human race we believe
there's even a 1% chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as it
greatest history of the world God versus
man
it's a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds
nice
but now if you wanted like you
I don't think you've ever known a woman
like me
now are you freezing
you know the oldest lie in America
but power can be innocent
oh my god
that looks really good oh yes looks
really good
yes holy [ __ ] do I feel good oh my god I
was awesome
you know what I've been saying for the
longest [ __ ] time what I've been
saying that they should do a Batman
movie where Batman is a real [ __ ]
martial artist I'm really getting that
here like he's really moving like a
martial artist yeah like in The Dark
Knight trilogy he moved kind of slow it
was it was martial arts but it wasn't
like this kind of martial arts where I'm
like this is some fancy [ __ ] they're
doing yeah and it looks [ __ ] badass
Bravo Rob I'm in it just for that and
the marketing teams getting smart
because this trailer really does make
you think Superman is like the one we're
gonna go against somebody should work
Batman I mean it says you know what I
don't care about any prior concerns I've
had really because he note was cool and
then we're dressed
yeah yeah because what was so cool about
it was this film showed us it has
personality you know it has a certain
style I hope it's just not a cool
trailer because the other trailers have
been so serious like yet so serious
which makes sense it was refreshing to
be like this could just be one badass
action movie you know I didn't get the
personality from it really
I didn't the biggest part of personality
I saw was the banter between Batman and
his guy yeah man
Alfred yes the banter between Batman and
Alfred was the only personality I saw
and maybe that's what the difference is
like it's mostly an action trailer and
that's why you totally dig it yeah I
love the trailer I just don't know if I
necessarily got the personality of the
of the film from it I mean when I say
personality I'm referring to like this
film seems like it actually has a sense
of fun that was my concern was like this
movie looks so serious is it going to be
fun at all but like you seen the music
they chose for the trailer seeing the
interaction like you said between Batman
and Alfred looks great I
like seeing sort of this you know I
don't know the word to kind of describe
Jeremy Irons as Alfred but he seems more
bold you know a little bit tougher yeah
which is more accurate to like the Frank
Miller depictions of Batman right one
thing this trailers really shown us too
is we're really gonna get a different
kind of Bruce Wayne yes you know like
especially after coming off the
Christian Bale Bruce Wayne I really feel
like he's got a different interpretation
of him that feels darker I really get
that sense of like he it has not been
Batman for a while but there's still
like this vengeance in him then yes to
be acted upon you know yeah it's kind of
like he's taking out something on
Superman Oh a bit more so again like I
really am sir like I get the vibe that
he's taking something out of him more
than he feels actually threatened by him
yes but there is logical explanation to
why he feels threatened but I think this
is for sure more a Batman trailer that
it is a Superman to a lot of that has to
do with where your sympathies lie by the
end of this trailer and I feel like
normal Superman I feel like everyone's
really looking forward to Batman so they
were smart in the marketing to make it
like alright let's let's have this focus
meeting a bad man what I want from the
movie is I want to be able to understand
both sides really well same thing on how
to feel about Captain America's Civil
War you know like I want to be able to
be in the audience and feel the conflict
of going back and forth of well Batman
has a point here uh Superman has a
pointy hair yeah who should I really
side with it's just two ideas I agree
with that are conflicting this trailer
was more like you're gonna root for
Batman you know Superman's kind of an
antiquated character yeah he's all like
good and justice and you know blah blah
and I feel like the conflict the inner
conflict that you said that Batman has
is so much more modern yeah yeah totally
I even like the teases of Wonder Woman
they gave me the trailer like I feel
like these are good teases because
they're showing her as a character like
they have the scene with her and Bruce
talking about like party or something
yeah I like that there's doing like it's
a little fanservice eat oh yeah totally
hey Jackie
yeah I mean in a lot of ways this film's
whole thing is this film feels weirdly
like imagined Justice League came out
than they did a prequel and it was this
movie yeah this kind of feels like a
prequel to Justice League and I guess if
I felt dawn of Justice so that makes
sense
course of course my fair shot of the
trailer was when is big Superman says
the punch and Batman just blocking in
Superman's like what the [ __ ] is going
on yeah and I and I'm watching it going
I want to know what that man is doing to
be able to overpower yeah this athlete
this children's eyes are glowing what's
going on
the marketing department listen to the
fans and were like last trailer showed
that they team up in the end everyone
knows what's going to happen but we
don't want to be so aware of that right
this trailer really emphasizes the
Batman vs Superman in a really good way
they made it look like it could be a lot
of fun the directing loves Zack Snyder
looks incredibly more solid than
manosphere stylistic cuz manners to you
matter steel I never seen it yet but
it's super handheld okay this film does
not look like handheld craziness that's
striking cinematography that is in he's
great with that he's a great visual
director right and I'm hoping if he
lacks and storytelling skills still I'm
hoping he makes up for that with a
really entertaining film okay you know
like Aaron it might not be that best
scripted thing but as long as it's
really entertaining which this trailer
was making me feel like it could be yeah
then I'm then I'm totally on board I'll
be satisfied all I really need is a good
action movie that can also make me laugh
yeah right and that's another thing
there was saying I want there were some
jokes thrown in here and the last
trailer it was so serious time when they
share a joke and it was like what yeah
here I'm like that was actually pretty
funny exactly yeah
I'm really satisfied with that trailer
listen guys if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become a reject or redo
like all kinds of reviews the video
that's cute and Brianna White has a
gaming channel if you're into games I'm
assuming because if your nerd watching
this you're probably know sorry my god
I'm so sorry did not mean a domestically
violent this situational is so awesome
so he's just punching me subscribe to
her or else I'm gonna beat her
I will beat her no Veronica don't let
this happen
me no I will beat the white I'll beat
the white out of you breathe you know
you cross